in rare cases a truly terrible
performance can actually improve a movie
transforming the mediocrity on display
into something so bad that it turns full
circle and becomes great in its own
right or at least enjoyable join us as
we take a look at the dreadful rolls
that might never win an Oscar but that
actually managed to make a film better
everyone's favorite flower shop customer
typifies the kind of bad acting that
people enjoy more than any other hi
doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye after writing directing
and starring in 2003's truly
inexplicable the room a film often
described as the Citizen Kane of bad
movies Tommy Wiseau became an industry
legend in ways that even he couldn't
predict fifteen years after we zou made
his big-screen debut the actors bizarre
accent exaggerated delivery and sheer
lack of acting ability had transformed
the room into a cult classic that
continues to be quoted by midnight movie
fans worldwide in the hands of anyone
else a script like this would just be
bad but we Zoe's baffling performance
somehow elevates these words into a
bizarrely hilarious curio that will
forever hold a place in Hollywood's Hall
of Fame you are lying I never hit you
you got a me partly job in the end we
Zoe's performance was so bad that it
wound up inspiring an entire
award-winning movie in 2017 James Franco
starred as we Sol and the disaster
artist a movie based on the making of
the room affecting his own inexplicable
accent and picking up a Golden Globe for
his troubles that's one of the few times
that anyone's been given an award for
being good at bad acting sometimes a
movie deserves every bit of it's bad
reputation and 1995's allegedly erotic
thriller showgirls is definitely not
great according to director Paul
Verhoeven however that was always the
intent elizabeth Berkley who starred as
Nomi Malone deliberately pushed her
trashiness to previously unseen extremes
precisely because he told her to in an
effort to deliver exactly the kind of
performance that he felt the script from
Jo Astor house required well it ain't
right you got too much talent for it to
be right while critics trashed the movie
when it hit theaters audiences have
since learned to embrace the ludicrous
dialog and can't be acting of showgirls
holding a particularly special place in
their hearts for Berkeley and the way
she played know me from her
cringe-worthy attempts at dancing to
that infamous scene
the swimming pool Berkeley's performance
has become one of the all-time greats in
cult cinema it's just a shame that our
attempts to turn people on and
ultimately turned casting directors off
in an effort to distance herself from
the good girl she played on Saved by the
Bell
Berkeley wound up tanking her acting
career at what could have been its
height after returning to the spotlight
with his iconic role in Quentin
Tarantino's Pulp Fiction in 1994 John
Travolta could have done just about
anything
unfortunately what he decided to do with
his newfound glory and millions of his
own dollars was produced a sci-fi epic
that became one of the most notorious
flops in cinema history based on a novel
written by l ron Hubbard the founder of
Scientology Battlefield Earth became a
legendary failure for both audiences and
fans virtually every aspect of the film
was panned with critics condemning
everything from the confused direction
to the ludicrous plot holes but
particular attention was given to
Travolta's role in the film the longtime
Scientologist played Turell a member of
the cycle battle fielders ten-foot-tall
world conquering aliens who kept man
animals as slaves to turn a profit for a
space corporation short of twiddling an
imaginary mustache Travolta's pantomime
performance went so far over the top
that it became the only thing in a movie
that was otherwise mind-bogglingly
monotonous that was actually fun to
watch despite its now legendary critical
mauling Travolta still maintains that
Battlefield Earth is actually an
underrated classic that doesn't deserve
its bad reputation
he's even claimed in interviews that if
he had to do it all over again he'd
still take the role blaming the media
for its negative image sounds like he
really did want those endless options
for renewal after all and a misguided
attempt to recapture the campy magic of
the 60s Batman TV show director Joel
Schumacher and writer Akiva Goldsman set
the superhero genre back decades with
their second collaboration starring the
Dark Knight from it's gaudy production
values to those unforgettable bat
nipples
Batman and Robin has regularly top lists
compiling the worst movies of all time
since its release in 1997 bull
Schumacher and star George Clooney have
even apologized for their roles in
in the film to life regretting how
Batman and Robin temporarily brought the
franchise to an end before it was
rebooted eight years later however
anyone who's seen the film knows that no
apology is necessary it might have some
pretty significant flaws but it's a
movie that knows exactly what it wants
to be and also brought us the campy
delight that has Arnold Schwarzenegger
in the role of mr. freeze show some
mercy yes see I'm afraid that the
condition is left be cold and a huge
departure from the more serious action
roles that he was known for like
Terminator and predator Schwarzenegger
steak on the ice cold villain took
action movie puns to the next level
warped killed the dinosaurs freeze takes
great delights and turning every line
into a gag and in hindsight it's hard to
imagine anyone else but Arnie managing
to get through any of it without either
breaking into laughter or bailing on the
film entirely 1987's big-screen
adaptation of masters of the universe
was inspired by the beloved 80s cartoon
in toy line mixing Mattel's story of
he-man and Eternia with elements from
unrelated comics by Jack Kirby the
co-creator of the Marvel Universe given
Hemans popularity and how much people
have turned out to love Kirby's
creations in their massive cinematic
universe that probably seems like a good
idea for a blockbuster franchise it was
not
schedule I start up a yoga for reviews
and lackluster box office earnings put
an end to hopes for a sequel and even
contributed to the imminent closure of B
movie icon Canon films but it seems that
most people missed the point
sure he Mann's ongoing Ward and Skeletor
is clunky and poorly made
but Masters of the Universe also
deserves to be celebrated as it can't be
classic in its own right mostly due to
Dolph Lundgren's performance in the lead
role wielding a sword in little Alice
Lundgren and Bude he-man with a goofy
charm that resonated with an entire
generation of children who were
overjoyed to see their hero on the big
screen at last using any measure known
to man it's clear that longer ins
performance will never be considered as
good in any objective interpretation of
the work but his portrayal of the
character on screen has made what could
have been a forgettable toy tie-in into
a fascinating cult classic like Robin
Hardy's original 1973 take on The Wicker
Man the 2006 remake revolves around the
search for a missing girl on a remote
island however unlike the first Wicker
Man film the newer version starring
Nicolas Cage amidst the horror in favor
of unintentionally hilarious comedy
spawning hundreds of snarky reviews from
critics and countless more memes from
the Internet at large how'd it get
burned
you'd purely as a remake of the horror
classic the 2006 version of the weaker
man is definitely not a good film after
all the original remains a masterclass
in suspense in paranoia and this new
imitation simply doesn't hold out
however if you're willing to put aside
any notions of horror and embrace cages
bizarre performance for what it is then
the new Wicker Man is arguably one of
the best comedies ever made
it's hard to tell whether cage played
the part for laughs or was genuinely
sincere in the role but either way his
overacting here is truly a marvel to
behold with an animal-like intensity
cage blazes across the screen screaming
about bees and punching women while
wearing a bear costume there's nothing
else out there quite like it and if the
film's box-office failure is anything to
go by then there will probably never be
anything like this again it's rather
ironic than a movie about a futuristic
cop that acts as judge jury and
executioner has become a guilty pleasure
for many but that's exactly what's
happened in the years since Sylvester
Stallone brought Judge Dredd to the big
screen in 1995 the film was originally
considered to be a box office flop
domestically and since it lacked the
satirical tone and stern stone-faced
scowl of the original British comic book
character it didn't resonate with casual
moviegoers or diehard fans of 2084 that
fans would have to wait another 17 years
but interest in the property has ensured
that Stallone's Judge Dredd will never
be forgotten completely one particular
sticking point for fans of the comic was
the fact that Stallone took off the
helmets and revealed dreads face in the
movie this is something that the
character would never have done in the
source material and still hasn't in over
40 years of comics then again if
Stallone hadn't wanted to get his mug on
camera we would never have received a
gift of his hilariously goofy facial
expressions for Judge Joseph
the sheer absurdity peaks at the end of
the film during an argument shared
between Dredd and his evil clone Rico
escalating to the point where both
forget how to pronounce basic words in
English you kill the knees to an end
the gibberish that both actors screaming
each other has since become immortalized
online thanks to an endless stream of
parodies that ensure Judge Dredd will
hold a special place in the hearts of
cinephiles everywhere plus we got a much
more accurate adaptation simply titled
Dredd in 2012 that did a far better job
of capturing what the character is
really all about making Stallone
cinematic failure a lot easier for fans
to take in the same tradition as the
Beatles a hard day's night in 1964 and
the Monkees cult film head in 1968 the
Spice Girls brought their own unique
brand of girl power to cinemas
everywhere in 1997 capitalizing on both
their record-breaking success and the
world's pre fascination with cool
Britannia predictably spice world broke
box office records and even more
predictably the critics load it for the
most part however even the most hardened
journalists must admit that there's
something infectious ly fun about the
film sure there's not much of a plot to
speak up and yes none of the girls ever
made the headlines for their acting
ability but thanks to the bubbly
charisma of the stars and a roster of
wild cameos that includes Elvis Costello
and meatloaf and a minor role spice
world continues to spice up the lives of
fans everywhere two decades on spice
world even got a re-release in UK
cinemas to celebrate its 20th
anniversary in 2017 suggesting that the
Spice Girls still retain their retro
charm
since spice world was first released the
girls have gone their separate ways and
reunited more than once but none of that
matters while watching the film spice
world is a bright and breezy time
capsule of a unique period in pop music
history one that wouldn't happen without
the brash positivity of the girls
themselves each of whom elevate the plot
silly trappings into something
undeniably silly yet ultimately
engrossing every now and again a movie
comes along that defies the odds and
fails in every conceivable way more than
any other film on this list troll 2 is
that movie from the totally implausible
plot to the fact that not even a single
troll appears in the film this night
18:19 oh budget disaster is a
catastrophe in every sense of the word
redefining what the word bad truly means
Michael yeah boy the goblins the story
itself follows a family who try and stop
vegetarian goblins from turning them
into plants but that doesn't really
matter what does matter is the atrocious
performances on display which help the
film develop a cult following that led
to numerous screenings at midnight movie
festivals and a documentary called best
worst movie in 2009 which chronicled the
many problems experienced onset while
it's difficult to pinpoint the single
worst performance in troll 2 the one
that's gained the most notoriety over
the years comes courtesy of Darrin Ewing
whose character reacts in horror at the
sight of a woman being devoured by
goblins and delivers a line that we
become a viral sensation years later
sure it's a bad movie maybe the worst
movie but there's no way to watch that
clip without having a fun time watching
it and there are plenty of Hollywood
blockbusters that can't claim that check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]